hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast deafness in the genomic era
discovery challenges and opportunities i
am kristen courage and heel of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots for more information please visit
lab roots comm this event is sponsored
by agilent technologies agilent is a
leader in life sciences diagnostics and
applied chemical market the company
provides laboratories worldwide with
instruments services consumables
applications and expertise enabling
customers to gain the insight base week
agilent's expertise and trusted
collaboration give people the highest
confidence in their solution we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problems through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining a credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Haley SES kayla is a research
scientist at the molecular
Otolaryngology and renal research
laboratories or mor L at the University
of Iowa USA she received her BA
of science and her Master of Science
degrees in biological engineering at the
University of Stax in Tunisia and her
PhD in human molecular genetics at the
University of Stax conjointly with the
University of Iowa
after completing about post doctoral
fellowship at the MOR L at the
University of Iowa Kayla was appointed
as assistant professor at the Pasteur
Institute of Tunis in Tunisia after
working there for two years on
characterizing the genetic etiology of
coarsen diseases in the tunisian
population she returned back to the USA
where she is currently leading the
hearing research team at the MOR el her
current research program is focused on
the discovery of novel genes genetic
modifiers and non-coding regulatory
elements involved in hereditary deafness
as well as the investigation of genetic
contribution to age and noise induced
hearing loss she's in charge of
developing next-generation sequencing
platforms and gene panels along with
creating solutions to improve
interpretation and clinical correlation
of genomic variants she aims to
translate novel knowledge acquired
through research into clinical
Diagnostics I will now turn it over to
dr. as I as for her presentation Thank
You Kristin for this introduction and
thanks everyone for joining us today I
am very excited to talk to you about
some of the projects we are working on
at the molecular Otolaryngology and
renal Research Laboratories at the
University of Iowa today I will be
presenting our experience with the
genetic evaluation of individuals with
hearing loss using a targeted genomics
panel we have developed in our lab we
will present the challenges we have
faced and the solutions we have created
to overcome them we will also show some
specific cases to highlight the genetic
and phenotypic complexities of
hereditary deafness to start I would
like to give an overview of hearing loss
hearing loss is
most common sense or the defect in
humans it affects 316 million people
worldwide and by 2020 that number is
projected to reach a billion both
environmental and genetic causes have
been involved in in the etiology of
hearing loss of iron mental causes such
as viral infection and ototoxicity
account for around 20% of cases the
remaining 80% are due to genetic causes
this ratio between environment and
genetic causes depends on the regional
location where genetic codes are more
prevalent in developed countries
compared with increased environmental
codes in developed countries the genetic
codes could be actually classified into
two categories sand Romick deafness
which in addition to the hearing loss
there is a defect in another organ or
tissue either stand alone for example is
the association of hearing loss with the
recognises pigmentosa what embankment
Rome is a combination of several
conditions including hearing loss and
changes in segmentation of the hair skin
or eyes and Pendred syndrome that is an
association between hearing loss and
greater however 70% of hearing loss is
actually nonfat drama or isolated and of
this 80% is recessive
whereas 20% is dominant hearing loss one
of the most striking characteristics of
hearing loss is that it is you know
typically heterogeneous it could be from
Soria knodel or conductors depending on
its location in the year or for example
for Tory neural hearing loss is due to
defect in the inner ear
whereas a conductive hearing loss is the
middle ear is affected hearing loss is
also characterized by the age of onset
it could be pre language forced Lincoln
or others onset by the severity which
goes from mild to moderate to severe to
profound the frequencies of
access could be either low frequency mid
frequencies or high frequencies the
symmetry of the hearing loss where both
is could be affected the same or not and
finally the progression which is the the
rate with which hearing loss progress
over age the different combination of
all these characteristics gives rise to
a wide range of phenotypic outcomes it's
not surprising then that that complex
phenotypic landscape is mirrored on the
molecular level as well over the past
two decades of genetic research into
deafness a lot of genes have been
identified as you could see here and the
rate of death gene discovery for
deafness has tremendously accelerated
since the advent of next-generation
sequencing with over a hundred fifty
genes identified to date and over 7,000
reported mutations an additional
challenge and studying deafness is the
complex and inaccessible structure where
the defect lies and this is the cochlear
here is a simplified image of a
cross-section of the cochlear surrounded
by genes known to cause hearing loss
it's easy to appreciate the diversity of
molecules involved divide a diversity
both in function and type with some
involve it in ion homeostasis while
others have a more structural role and
others acting as transcription factors
the spatial expression of this protein
this protein is also complex with some
expressive in specific cell type such as
have cell versus aquatic cells and all
the genes being expressed as specific
compartments within the cell itself set
such as um stereocilia or mid
mitochondria this extraordinary
phenotypic genetic and allelic
heterogeneity makes genetic screening of
individuals with hearing loss laborious
challenging and time-consuming
to address this challenge we capitalized
on advances in sequencing technologies
to develop a next-generation sequencing
platform that we called otoscope
otoscope is a targeted genomics irishman
panel that includes 152 genes associated
with hearing loss these genes are linked
to nonsense Romick hearing loss all of
the non central hearing loss are
included in our panel but we have also
included genes that are involved in some
Center omics forms such as after centrum
Pendred syndrome and also some common
form of syndromic are hearing loss like
ahlstrom
borscht and Rome or Wolfram syndrome
otoscope are is regularly updated by
adding or removing genes based on new
data published so the next step is
actually to perform target sequence
capture and we use the algae on short
electoral tapes get to capture all these
exons and and make our origin libraries
we then use Illumina high seek for
massively parallel sequencing as you are
all familiar with next-generation
sequencing to generate an enormous
amount of data that needs to be
processed over the past six years we
have developed and refined a custom
pipeline custom genetic pipeline
specifically for hereditary hearing loss
this pipeline is comprehensive and it
includes both automated steps covered
with manual curation and expert review
steps so the first step is actually
needs to get the raw sequence data
process map and align it to the
reference genome we then do some
filtering for quality and for annotation
it's also important to notice that we
see empty analysis is an integral part
of our bio informatics pipeline after
that
the second step is variant will drink so
we start with filtered variants
according to their quality so we only
keep variance with the depth of coverage
over 10 present in 50% of the reeds and
a few G more than 5 we then look at the
functional relevance of the variants we
look at nonsynonymous by sight variance
or in Dells we then also a big part of
the pipeline is a minor allele frequency
so we usually end up around 10 variants
per sample these are candidates that we
will review in a weekly multi
disciplinary meeting attended by
clinicians scientists geneticists by
optimizations and genetic counselors and
we discuss the phenotypic and genotypic
data and see if the genetic data
actually is correlated could be
correlated to the phenotype for deaths
of specific case for this we have action
the best workflow we have created and
used several key tools which are unique
to our pipeline two of these tools are
our the deafness variation database or
gdg and the second one is audio gene use
it for a geometric profile and I will
take all talk a little bit more about
these two arms and the next few slides
so after we prioritize variants the
second the last part is actually to
confirm this variance so with with our
form variance week before it we perform
Sanger sequencing and if all the
individuals from the families are
available we could also do segregation
analysis to concern best variant the
last step would be to generate the
genetic report that is sent to the
clinician you could appreciate from here
genetic variant classification is
crucial to accurate genetic diagnosis
and represents a major challenge in the
post genome era
to address this challenge we have
designed a definite specific database
called the deafness variation database
to provide continuously updatable
comprehensive resource for variant
classification for hearing loss this
database is built on a custom and
terminal bio informatics pipeline that
collects variants and their annotations
for all deafness genes so the gene list
is regularly updated by adding or
removing the genes faces on you data so
we review all the genes before including
them in our pipeline in our otoscope
platform typically then gathered all
information available for all the
variants that are present in these genes
and we collect the data from DB snips
from clinvar from a DMV exact EDS and
1000 Genomes these vary then we'll go a
set of automated annotation and
classification we use DNS SP to add
pathogenicity scores we use a police and
mutation taster under t sift verb and
file P to annotate for pathogenicity and
conservation an important step here is a
minor allele frequency we use the cutoff
of 0.5% for research of hearing loss and
point zero five percent for dominant
hearing loss after the step of automated
annotation the variance will undergo
calculated clinical significance so it's
X epsilon where we need and we discussed
all these variants in the context of the
phenotypic expression in individuals
with hearing loss so all these variants
then are stored and they are freely
available and the DVD
website to tell you how many variants
are present in DVD that you see there
it's over 170,000 variants are present
and each DVD of those approximately
seventy four seventy four hundred
parents are annotated and classified as
pathogenic
672 are likely pathogenic and you could
appreciate that the biggest part of all
variants and DVD are actually variant of
uncertain significance and this is one
of the biggest challenges that not only
in the research for hearing loss but for
all other genetic diseases is those
variants of unknown significance and
that secondly what makes the DVD very
relevant to what we do so because it is
designed as a deafness specific and it
correlates all available data and it
also provides expert manual curation for
all these variants involved in disease
so while many laboratories use the
publicly available resources such as
clinvar and a GMG to help with variant
interpretation we have noticed that
there is some discrepancies between the
DVD and both clinvar and hgmd in fact
when we compared both the data and
classification of variants between our
clinvar and DVD we have noticed that
14.5 percent have discovered
classification when we did the same with
a GMD we not discuss almost 5% of
variants i have discounted
classifications between a GMP
and end gdbg so why is that on one of
the reasons and the shortcomings of the
clinvar is that sometimes some variants
would have multiple submissions with
conflicting classifications for a GMG we
do know that their data is actually
resist restricted to published papers so
any old political labs or research labs
you won't have any of their variants in
a GMP endless death data was published
and a common
remark we have made is that the DVD more
commonly downgrade clean water energy
edge EMV classification what that means
is for all these discordance discarded
calls actually DVD would say these
variants are not pathogenic they are
more likely to be varied of a
nonsignificant or sometimes they are
actually just denied variants one of the
also the issues are for people
annotating and classifying genetic
variants is that we try to follow the
ACMG guidelines but sometimes these are
hard to follow because they are more
generic so they are not disease specific
and for definite and for other diseases
there need to be a tailored ACMG
guidelines and they think that now clean
part is a starting on expert panel for
specific diseases and which will be
really great because we can tailor on
the guidelines to each specific disease
and most importantly we will include in
those guidelines expert knowledge and
curation so here is just an overview of
the variants that are only involved in
hearing loss because some of the genes
that are an otoscope are both involved
with in hearing loss but sometimes are
also involved in other disorders so we
only kept the ones that are involved in
hearing loss and we made the comparison
between for example clinvar best to DVD
and deaf table we understood we only put
the major categorical changes what we
call major categorical changes is any
change into or out of pathogenic and
likely pathogenic so you see the
horizontal lines the red ones are
usually getting upgraded from a B us
benign or likely benign to likely
pathogenic or pathogenic the blue ones
are more downgraded which are going from
pathogenic or likely pathogenic and
downgraded to either view of variant of
uncertain significance or likely benign
and benign
looking at these two figures we can
appreciate that after expert review
operation actually more than 300 major
categorical changes were made and the
DVD when compared to a G and D and
clinvar and this is really really
important to keep in mind
so variant interpretation is actually
one component and we believe that to be
able to to be able to correlate those
variants to the phenotype itself we need
to find a way to check the concordance
between in our case hearing loss the
concordance between audiogram and
variants identified by comprehensive
genetic screening in person with hearing
loss so we have developed to address
this challenge we have developed audio
gene through a long-standing
collaboration with the Department of
Engineering at the University of Iowa
audio gene is a supervised support
vector machine learning algorithm that
uses audiometric data to predict
genotypes for example the first version
for Georgie uses 30 2014 6 sorry 3246
audiogram collected from over 1,400
person with autosomal dominant nonce and
Romek hearing loss associated with 34
deafness genes for each of these genes
or gene averages or the audiogram in our
data set and group them into two decades
increments to obtain an audio profile
and we have shown that some genes
exhibit distinct for do profiles
making it possible to predict the
genetic codes of a person's hearing loss
from just entering their audiogram on
audio gene website photo gene can also
be used to define audio profile surfaces
so audio profile surface it's the normal
method
of represented of representing a
geometric datum that incorporates age as
the third dimension that's the novelty
about that so instead of the usual 2g
audiogram we now have a 3G audiogram as
shown in this figure representing
hearing loss associated with KPMG 4G in
addition to frequency and disabled age
is included to show average reading
threshold over time by using audio
profile surfers a clinician can provide
a person with a hearing loss specific
genetic specific genetic type of hearing
loss a direct comparison on how that
person's hearing compares to expected
threshold for that gene at a given age
you see teal with the with the red line
on the audio profile circle
it also helps make an acute prognosis of
the deterioration of their hearing you
think that methodology are we have we
won't also make that um gene specific
audio profile surfaces they can also be
studied using here people surface
clustering to determine whether
sub-clusters provides a better or more
appropriate fit for the data here T call
surface clustering was developed as a
tool to explore where the novel
subclasses for each gene should be
considered for example we have here two
examples using KC and p4 again as an
example here people surface clustering
identified two distinct sub-clusters
once associated with the missense
mutation
showing a gently sloping order profile
server and the second sub cluster
associated with truncating mutation
showing a more severe phenotype here
peak on surface clustering is also
valuable tool to identify patients and
subgroups that likely reflect the
presence of genetic modifier and the
example shown here here peak on surface
class
and actually provides to subclusters 1 &
2 that are not dependent of mutation
location or time or age l or gender so
there is no compounding factors which
actually are my hint to the presence of
genetic modifiers the problem I have
shown you two unique components of our
genetic analysis pipeline
however testing the positive result is
more like putting together a puzzle we
have to take into account different
pieces in order to establish holistic
and comprehensive review of the genetic
results we have to include the variant
frequency or variant type the test to
segregate on in the family if there are
more individuals available on the
phenotype making the phenotypic
correlation pathogenicity projections
and finally if there is any functional
data available for the variant so using
the method I have described
we have analyzed over 5000 samples to
date we use the combined knowledge
provided by both the positive and the
negative cases so positive cases are the
cases where we were able to identify the
genetic mutations in known deafness gene
negative is no diagnosis could be made
one important thing is you I'm going to
share with you the data we got for
screening all these cases the overall
solve rate is around 50% but it is
hugely influenced by several factors one
of them is the inheritance mode with
autosomal recessive cases showing more a
higher overall solve rate than autosomal
dominant the other thing is ethnicity
and you could appreciate that
cases with African descent have the
lowest solve rate amongst all population
of study
and that is still true and it's actually
a good motivation to studied this
population more in order to identify
novel genes at the other spectrum we
could see that populations where
consanguinity is culturally accepted the
solve rate is the highest and that is
due mostly to homozygosity because these
continuous marriages usually produce
homozygosity and the solve rate is is
really higher and sometimes it's about
even a hundred percent the genetic also
worms also we have shown that some genes
are more prevalent than others here this
is the average general our gene
prevalence and I would like to emphasize
here but for all the patients I am
talking about we have excluded the ones
that we're gjb to positive which meaning
that the ones we have found a mutation
and gjb to we did that because most of
the samples we get have already
undergone gjb to testing and they were
negative and we thought that including
them including surgery table though the
patients which you should be two
mutations with school kind of the
results and the statistical analysis so
we just excluded them from this from the
rest of our analysis so we considered
SSE 26:34 my 15a ketamine 23 are the
most prevalent genes and this have
already been shown before the
interesting part here is the spectrum
and prevalence is actually also ethnic
dependent and you could appreciate here
how each population has a different gene
on gene parallel one also the that we
were interested in is to see the variant
type and we saw
for both recessive and dominant most of
the variants identified are normal and
for example for dominant only 20% of the
variants that are identified in patients
with hearing loss with autosomal
dominant hearing loss are only 20% 20%
are only 20% of them are already known
pathogenic and to add another layer of
complexity of all the variants that are
identified almost half of them are
variants of unknown significance and
that's actually what makes things come
as we talked about it earlier really
complicated we have also seen that
missense mutations are more prevalent in
dominant and that nonsense and
truncating mutations are more prevalent
in the recessive and recessive hearing
loss which we have expected on before
what I would like to get your attention
to is the c and v evaluate here and
which until now is like till the advent
and the implementation of
next-generation sequencing
C and V analysis was very costly and
time-consuming to screen for and I am
going to show you a few more examples of
the importance of CMV for example we
have we have shown that C and these can
be found in about 20% of deafness coding
regimes and most of these cnvs are
actually whole gene deletions of the
whole genius deleted we have also seen
our duplications and conversions most of
the time those 3 MVS are homozygous they
could also be heterozygous with another
single nucleotide variant on the other
allele so with all these positive cases
there are few things that we can learn
from and one of the most important thing
that is relevant not only for research
but also
on Diagnostics and for genetic
counseling is genotype-phenotype
correlation and depending on those genes
and those data for independence on those
variants and their phenotype we could
actually show on some genetic complexity
we could expand the phenotype of some of
the genes for example they were shown
before to only be associated with
dominant versus recessive or centralized
versus non sentronics one of the
important things we can actually also
study is genetic modifiers and in the
next of my slides I am going to go
through each of these three categories
so we will start with the genotypic
complexity and our first case is a five
year old Irish female with congenital
severe to profound sensorineural hearing
loss as the family history showed an
extended family with hearing loss and a
mother with white forelock for those of
you who are not familiar with on some of
the genetic obligatory hearing loss a
white firlock or a problem of pigment of
pigmentation in association with hearing
loss is a strong indicator of
Waardenburg syndrome so this sample this
case was referred to us after a negative
result from another institution so they
are one group Waardenburg panel step and
it came out negative when we are this
sample in our pipeline we couldn't find
any single nucleotide variants in any of
the genes associated with Waardenburg
syndrome but what we found is actually a
heterozygous two eggs on deletion in
sox10 so we actually solved this case
because of the presence of the c and v
and that actually really highlights the
importance of integrating CMV detection
in any net generation sequencing femoral
for hearing loss
our second case is also to highlight the
importance of CNG so this case is a
six-month-old with mild to moderate
bilateral non-standard ohmic hearing
loss and there is negative family
history
so our CNG analysis indicated a
homozygous deletion of this video
challenging we could have stopped there
because that would explain their hearing
loss however one of the interesting
characteristic of this genomic location
of video spell engine is a check the
duplicated
region and you could see here that
stereo saline lies next to capture 2 and
that on several head escapees later
variants to the gene SDLP an SDS CP 1
and when our our analysis pipeline
actually also screened the region that
whole region including stereo chillin
cats purr to subsidy G and the pseudo
gene and what we have seen there is that
it's actually not a deletion ox video
spillin but rather a gene tube so the
gene conversion through a non allelic
homologous recombination that was really
amazing that because before we just
assume it is just a deletion of stereo
set and we're here we are shown actually
the third region is prone to genomic
rearrangements and in this case there is
a conversion on from the gene to the
potato gene so here is another case
again we see a homozygous deletion of
the stereo filling in a 1 year old male
with mild to moderate hearing loss and a
family history that is negative so here
on again it's the homozygous deletion in
stereo silence the third gene was normal
when we screened it so that would have
been DSN be 16 which means it's nonsense
Romek hearing loss however our pipeline
also screened for capture - and what you
see here is actually also a homozygous
deletion of capsule
- why this is important buttons actually
very important because truncating
mutations in capture - has been
associated with male infertility so
homozygous deletion of the stereo
Sternin and capture - actually will give
rise to deafness and fertility central
so this boy is going to be a vessel
which is really very important for for
the family to know and for genetic
counseling later we have shown um till
now a whole gene deletions or cut regime
deletions but we need also to emphasize
the importance of single gene so single
eggs on deletion that is the need for a
high-resolution CMV detection in case
for this is an 11 year old female with
congenital profound sensorineural
hearing loss she was adopted so we don't
have a family history but she had a
heterochromia Iridum
white firlock and sliced bracket
actually we did a otoscope and we found
that there is one single exons deletion
that would have been a completely
message if it was done by Sanger
sequencing or if we just screen it on
next-generation sequencing but without
GNP analysis the next case is actually
also really interesting this is an 8
year old male are always continued on
moderate sensorineural hearing loss
negative family history and the physical
exam only showed myopia and this is
their their audiogram so when we perform
at photos club we found actually a
homozygous stop rotation on auto Gellin
this is already a known pathogenic
mutation so this is a great so how this
person is actually occurring or
homozygous
shock mutation the story could have
ended here however when we did our CNVs
we actually detected a head
distribution in Auto chi'lan so that's
variant whistle and we thought is hormoz
right but it's actually hemizygous and
the the etiology and the genetic codes
for the phenotype in this case is
actually compound heterozygosity for one
stop mutation in one allele and the
deletion in the other this is completely
will change on genetic counseling and
carrier screening is really important
one of the other also a challenges and
we have encountered and some of also of
the cool cases is genetic heterogeneity
in one family
for example the families of Iranian
descent segregating severe to profound
nonce and Romek hearing loss and
exhibiting several loops of
consanguinity so we sent one individual
for otoscope the results came out with a
homozygous mutation in Calgary in 23 so
great we did segregation analysis
Turner's relative surprise best variant
only segregated in one branch the other
branch not have been even carry this
variant so we sent another patient from
the other branch to screen by protocol
we found actually homozygous - event a
mutation and then when we did the
segregation analysis after no doubt that
this mutation all disaggregated and the
other branch of the family there is only
one individual who both was homozygous
for post mutations and that was actually
also really important to screen when it
is a big family it is better to screen
on a couple of individuals just
especially from different pressures just
to make sure we are not missing anything
here with this case we are going to add
another layer of complexity um so this
is an Iranian family with Usher syndrome
type 1 that's the most severe on kind of
Usher syndrome we can best person for
other group and it was negative
so we said oh this is a great family
event for holding some sequencing to
identify the normal gene because we
thought on none of the known genes
explained the phenotype in this family
so we sent from best patient and
actually two others for holding some
sequencing to our surprise we found out
that actually the two other patients
actually carried on to known pathogenic
mutation in ashwin see this Ashwin T has
been already linked to Usher syndrome
type 1 this weapon dividual actually did
not have any none of the variants we
contacted the clinician and then they
went back a check and then it turned out
that that patient had only some kind of
eye disorder that they called retinitis
pigmentosa so completely changing the
spin of the phenotype genotype for this
patient when we analyze the best
patients our total exam sequencing by
himself we actually discovered a
mutation and see AC and a 1f
and that is our x-linked and mutation
NCAP and a1f have already been involved
with in our congenital stationary night
blindness that is kind of our p light or
control disrupting so for this actually
family there are two distinct phenotypes
and three disc genes in one family
because on the third generation the
affected girl in the third generation we
still could not explain her hearing loss
it might be coming from her father
because he is a marriage in but that is
just to highlight some of those
complexities we are talking about
another interesting case is we got vest
43 year old made with biological
profound hearing loss and known family
history and the clinical diagnosis was
actually a sure sandal but when we
perform with genetic testing we found
that he is actually carrier for two
pathogenic mutation a 30 26 1/4 that
explains his hearing loss and another
relation in over one which explains the
optic atrophy
so actually we change the diagnosis
completely from
and Rome - just on non-central make
hearing loss due to a 30 26 a 4 and
optic addressing the second class of of
thing that we learned from genotypes or
at acceleration is phenotypic expansion
and I'm going to talk about a best
family where we have identified a
mutation canonical splice site mutation
and code 11 a 1 segregating with the
disease and that autosomal dominant
non-standard on the hearing loss so what
we knew before is that mutation Khalid
ib'n anyone have been only linked to
stickler and Marshall Center on this is
the first time that rotational Khalid
ib'n watt kaa one has been associated to
autosomal dominance and romic hearing
loss the second case is with PT p RQ BGP
untii you have today it has only been
linked to autosomal recessive notes and
roma hearing loss that is severe to
profound and their family we found it
associated with autosomal dominant don't
send Roma hearing loss and since
recessive mutations are like our null
null alleles or lack of function so we
predict that on the mode of mechanism of
PGP our dominant mutations in PT p or q
are gain-of-function or dominant
negative we have also shown are that p
DVD 7 is actually a causative for dance
and drama hearing loss because till now
PG DD 7 has only been shown to be just a
modifier for for the retinal phenotype
in ash - so the all these are really
important for again for diagnosis for
genetic counseling for career screening
and just even to shed light and some of
the complexities and of hearing loss so
the next part I'm going to talk about
genetic modifiers and here is a family
basically gates autosomal recessive
nonce and romic hearing loss and we
found two mutations
TMC one gene its aggregators in the
family the only thing here interesting
thing is two patients exhibit a more
severe profile a more severe phenotype
than the two others so to exhibit on
only high-frequency hearing loss where
are the two others exhibit a profound
hearing loss so here we suspected that
is the enter and intervention of a
genetic modified but contested genetic
modifiers it is making the phenotype or
if it makes it is actually protected we
went back to the lecture to look so
literature but also through some of the
cases we had before and we notice that
those mutations are actually have been
linked to severe to profound hearing
loss in other patients which section is
like you shall think that what we are
looking for here is the more generic
modifier that would protect from the
full effect of GMT one mutations so
hypothesis for this outsiders phenotype
is it could have been also due to sorts
with this mutation in a second gene but
we have already checked for that by
sending or by a perform an otoscope and
genetic screening in all these patients
but we couldn't find any variant in no
deafness codes in the gene that would
segregate with the outlier phenotype on
the other hypothesis as I said earlier
pseudo genetic inheritance or a genetic
modifier and for that we plan on
performing whole exome sequencing and
whole genome sequencing and studied the
pathway and interaction of protein that
would interact with GM c1 or modulate
its effect so what is next so I have
think about the positive cases and how
they actually provide a better
understanding of hearing mechanism and
how if they open many doors but what
about the negative cases the negative
cases are actually really interesting
because
these patients and cases are great
candidate for noble gene discovery there
are several ways and several other labs
use different approaches we do use a
huge approach for those negative cases
we would clean them with another
targeted genomic panel for candidate
genes that we have developed in the lab
these genes are energy rate decisions
our hair cells orest
and the mouse model for some of them are
deaf so these are great candidate
patients that are actually also negative
or Hearing Panel and we will go on to
perform whole exam sequencing and using
that strategy you is actually identified
several genes using this approach but as
you may expect and as you may know a lot
of these cases some of a lot of the
cages will remain unknown and
unidentified and for those are we could
again use targeted panels if you would
like to look for regulatory elements we
could also use whole genome sequencing
so there are different approaches and
different ways but they are all but they
all actually open doors for research
identifying novel genes identifying
regulatory elements identifying genetic
modifiers our pipeline actually make us
allowed to collect such really
interesting cohorts for further studies
and research so as a conclusion um I
would like just don't--i size a few
points here the targeted gene panel
rather than exams or genomes for
deafness offer an efficient
cost-effective customizable high
throughput and high depth
sequencing approach to detect rare
variants and CMV
speaking of cnvs their detection and
high resolution detection must be
integrated in all next-generation
pipelines for darkness it is also really
important to integrate the audio metric
and the genetic data to facilitate
interpretation of genetic variants
targeted gene panels could be used as
font and filter it will generate a
carefully selected study population
arrest for hearing impaired individuals
likely to carry mutations in novel genes
of non-coding variants in regulatory
regions I would like to thank all our
collab collaborators all over the world
for their help and great input I would
also like to thank all individuals and
families who participated in this
research would like to thank Richard
Smith of the director of the MOR L Kevin
booth graduate students in the lab and
also all people and team members at the
MOR L for their magnificent work and our
tireless are really unbelievable what we
are doing here I would like also to
thank Thomas Gavin Jerry Brown and
Michael Schneider from the College of
Engineering at the University of Iowa
and Jose in asthma belly and Kimmy Akagi
from the University of Social Welfare
and rehabilitation sciences in Iran all
these people helped has been and been an
invaluable and has advanced our
knowledge of the genetics of hearing
loss I would like to thank you for your
attention and I would be happy to answer
your questions and thank you again for
attending today's webinar
thank you for that informative
presentation and dr. ideas before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit question you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can in our first question is looking up
looking at otoscope vs. whole exome
sequence which one is a better option
and more reliable this is a great
question actually are we see the
discussion a lot and in our experience
we think that otoscope or targeted on
custom targeted panels outperform whole
exome sequencing because first the
otoscope targeted panel is actually
definitely specific so we included in
there there is all
besides the older coding exons there is
also variants that are indian coding
visions either enter onic or enter genic
we could also tie all four genes for C
and V detection and this is not possible
with good whole exome sequencing the
other thing is on otoscope because of
the great depth of coverage we could
actually accurately detect rare variants
guess is the accuracy is not the same
with whole exome sequencing and we have
done several studies and we have shown
that the detection rate with otoscope is
way greater than whole eggs on
sequencing some of the benefits of using
targeted panels are also the high
throughput and basically the cost
because as you know whole exam
sequencing is a more expensive and it's
not as high throughput as targeted
panels also one or the level of argument
for the use of targeted panels is the
ease of analysis
because here we are only looking at
deafness specific genes so that makes
the analysis easier more relevant and it
also kind of resolved the issue at the
challenge and the burden of incidental
findings and what to do with them and
you have a question okay great yes we
have another question how do you confirm
the C and B a second oh that's really
great a question and we have done
several studies before and we confirm it
our cnvs by MLP a we have also done a an
independent study to confirm our
analysis detection of detecting CNVs by
whole genome sequencing using array
comparative genomic hybridization we
also when it is possible we Sanger
sequence we do segregation analysis or
we send a sequence of breakpoints thank
you okay let's see for the next one
in your opinion what explains the
significant number of unsolved cases the
number of unsolved cases with its around
50 percent and again depending on the
population and ethnicity and studies but
there are several main reasons for this
high rate of interpret cases first
amongst them is we can only screen for
genes for knowledge in so the encoded
case is actually a lot of them would be
accounted for for a by novel genes yet
to be identified
another reason is we are not actually
screening for non-coding variants in
regulatory elements or even a you know
clip it could be an tronic on actor
genic so we are missing another whole
another whole class of variants which
are the non-coding one another reason
why is also the unrecognized
genotype-phenotype correlations i have
shown here a couple of examples with PT
p RQ and col 11 a1 and for example if it
was
diagnostic knob and they have autosomal
dominant family and then they found the
gene in our case a nonsense mutation in
PT PRQ they would not respect that this
is the code of this family hearing loss
because first it is a recessive gene and
second it was a nonsense mutation
so this unrecognized genotype on your
genotype correlation actually account
for we believe an important significant
proportion of I solve at least another
level is also the synonymous variance
because no one reporting on Ellis
variance because we do not believe they
are disease-causing but these variants
actually some of them could be or could
have enough loans and I couldn't
practice slicing and that they could be
also they could account actually for
some of the adult ages thank you okay
our next question we have what targeted
capture is the otoscope based off of and
how did you choose that technology so we
design it otoscope using agilent sure
select custom targeted capture so why we
use it
agilent because i think the main one of
the main reasons is first the design
flexibility we could actually put
anything we would like in our platform
it's custom it is personalized so it
could be in coding exons we put in their
promoter regions we put sometimes of the
single nucleotide variant that is entire
genic because you were interested on
those variants so the flexibility and
the design is a really good really
important factor another important
factor is the capture efficiency we have
had great success rate using the short
collect custom or capture because of its
efficiency one other
reason is also the ease of the
experimental design because it is fast
but it also could be automated and as
you saw we are used we have already
sequence over 5000 samples or automation
around and the ability to automate
sequencing is a big factor in our
decision thank you
okay let's see the next question we have
there are a large number of
discrepancies between DVD and hgmd and
clinvar what do you attribute this to so
clinvar one of the clinvar na GMD are
both great tools and great
databases and they give a phenomenal
help but they do also have a couple of
shortcomings with clean bar the fact
that one variant could have multiple
submissions because several labs put in
there like their own interpretation and
classifications and most some of the
time they are conflicting so it is
really hard to know which one is correct
sometimes for the term variant it could
be benign or pathogenic and then it's up
to the researcher or the clinician to
figure out which one is correct
also anyone can actually deposit in
clinvar so that also add another level
of change of the challenging for a GMG
on their variants are only based on
published literature so if a variant has
not been published before you will not
find it in a GMP also sometimes the
papers reference or that hgmd is based
on sometimes those papers are a little
confusing and our information is missing
regarding if it actually is
disease-causing or not so they just
report a variant and sometimes they are
not really clear if this one is for
example was found in France with another
mutation or adjust by itself so reading
those papers
to be are misleading and that's actually
what account for on those discrepancies
for the DVD since we do beyond the
automation step that classifies all
variants we actually also expect curate
all of those variants so we correlate
them to specific phenotypes because we
have seen them in one of our patients
outside this is over 5,000 patients so
we have seen a lot of variance and it
was possible for us actually to make a
collect call regarding those variants
thank you thank you alright the next one
we have what if the whole egg film comes
back with rare mutation of us H gene
what is the accuracy rate when the
otoscope is negative so as we show here
if this variant is an enone deafness
gene um all that are we are going to
detected using otoscope the only
challenge here and i presented one of
the cases here with um with the Ashwin
thief and you showed that because of the
luck of phenotypic characterization so
the clinical information we were getting
was not accurate and that led us to
actually not being able to find the
mutation but when we did whole exome
sequencing we found the mutation but we
found it whenever another gene that has
never been linked to just deafness so a
short answer would be using otoscope we
will find any mutation if it is in a
known deafness gene if the clinical was
not accurate to begin with it is hard
even if you use exams or any of the kind
of screening you will you want to be
able to find the correct genetic code
thank you okay what targeted capture is
otoscope a staffer how did you choose
the technology so again you can raise it
on short select custom targeted capture
we use it because it was um one of the
best and leading companies in this
domain
we also use actually by the way we also
you should select whole exome sequencing
so we use both the target the custom
target capture and the whole exome
sequencing target captured capture but
for two different research purposes we
always follow accurate approach in our
analysis so we always clean all patients
and all cases that we received using
otoscope the custom targeted panel and
then for everything that is negative we
couldn't find and identify any genetic
code for their hearing loss using
otoscope we will send them a we will
perform a whole exome sequencing using
the agilent sources should select ok -
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
now that we know the genetic makeup can
we do anything nutritionally or
medically to change the hearing loss
yeah this is one of the that we all aim
to actually all the basic research and
genetics
our final goal is actually to develop
therapies and the several studies that
have been made and a lot of them are
based in gene therapy some people are
using the SI RNAs and some people have
done it also for after syndrome and I
think it is a promising and again for
before any therapy could be developed we
really need to characterize the genetic
makeup but also for both recessive and
dominant because the therapies would be
different regard if it was dominant or
recessive and so yeah so that is the
traditionally the few studies are not
going to go there but medically and in
the gene therapy there are a lot of
things going on
Thank You wonderful I'm going to once
again thank thank dr. as well for her
presentation
do you have any final comments
no thank you I would like to thank
everyone for joining us it has been a
real pleasure and please feel free to
send me any questions because of the
time here the time limit but please feel
free to send me any question we will be
really happy to help answer any of your
questions and provide more information
thank you very much
thank you so much today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November of 2017 you will
receive an email from Lavery's alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event we'll see
you next time goodbye
you